bonjour aujourd'hui on va parler du
samsung galaxy s 9 et s9 plus qui
sortiront dans quelques temps alors vous
êtes déjà fait une vidéo et quelques
temps de 1h pour vous dire effectivement
qu'on allait retrouver dans ses
téléphones mais depuis il ya eu du
nouveau on a eu pas des rumeurs mais les
fuites et ça on va en parler
[Musique]
avant toute chose
samsung galaxy s le saint téléphone qui
va sortir l'année prochaine pour couper
l'herbe sous le pied à l'apple et à son
iphone dit ce téléphone a plusieurs
vocations mais ça on en parlera après
donc ce qu'on va faire dans cette vidéo
c'est que déjà on va regarder un petit
peu quelles sont les nouveautés quels
sont les fuites on va ensuite faire
passer dans le contexte des rumeurs pour
voir un peu quel est le vrai du faux et
pour vraiment dessiner le portrait robot
de ce téléphone qu'on va retrouver
l'année prochaine vous allez voir c'est
vraiment super intéressant parce que ce
téléphone en réalité il va faire bien
plus qu'être une nouvelle version et
puis une version surboosté dualité de la
suite plus mais surtout je dirais ça
permet vraiment de dessiner l'avenir on
va voir vraiment en avance on a vu qui a
l'intelligence artificielle qui avancent
de plus en plus il ya vraiment plein de
plein de choses qui se mettent en place
qui se met en branle on s'était
smartphones aujourd'hui en dix ans donc
on arrive maintenant dans la deuxième
décennie et on va vraiment arriver dans
quelque chose qui va être superbe ce
qu'on va faire tout de suite c'est qu'on
va regarder quels sont les fuites ces
fuites viennent pas de nulle part comme
d'habitude j'ai mon petit cahier ce qui
lui évite de faire des coupures à chaque
fois alors il ya des informations qui
viennent du site mobilefriends mobile
fun comme vous voulez je commençais à
l'anglais the move iphone qui vous donne
des infos du fabricant de la coque qui
s'appelle olic sar ce qui fait que qu'on
voit vraiment la découpe où sont les
zones où il va y avoir les différents
boutons est ce qu'il ya un port jack oui
non donc ça permet vraiment d'avoir une
info qui est vraiment fiable ensuite on
a des infos qui viennent de slash l'x
qui est aussi élu d accès à des
informations et puis ensuite de san
'mobile' qui a des informations
concernant la batterie donc tout ça on
va le regarder ensemble et vous allez
voir c'est super cool qu'est ce qu'on
apprend en regardant cette coque on
apprend que les boutons volume bouton
bixby bouton pour allumer pour éteindre
le smartphone ne bouge pas et restent au
même endroit on apprend également que
samsung a fait le choix de conserver sa
prise jack là où il ya beaucoup de
constructeurs compris la prise jack et
qu'ils ont mis à la poubelle qui l'ont
dégagée ça c'est vraiment au point un
point positif je trouve que garder le la
prise jack ça a vraiment un sens que ce
soit pour brancher un micro que ce soit
pour brancher des casques filaires on
n'est pas ou qu'on n'a pas tous envie de
s'acheter des casques bluetooth à devoir
recharger n'a pas tous envie de
s'embêter avec ça le fait pour garder
son casque et le branché c'est vraiment
parti on apprend également les
informations concernant la batterie
alors la batterie du s9 rapport suite
faut savoir que les suisses et une
batterie 3800 paire eur le s9 or une
batterie des 3200 milliampères heures
donc ya pas une énorme révolution de là
dedans donc s'étant pas forcément avoir
un téléphone beaucoup plus gourmand par
contre sans avoir un téléphone beaucoup
plus performants donc on imagine
complètement que la batterie va être
optimisée on peut aussi imaginer que va
tout le fonctionnement de l'appareil en
lui-même va être optimisée si vous
gardez une batterie de 3200 milliards
eur on est proche de 3 milan perdue du
produit que vous avez avant si vous
n'avez pas une optimisation au niveau du
matériel avec un écran qui va consommer
avec un processeur qui sera normalement
plus gourmands à brusquer la paix dont
ils vont retrouver un peu limité donc on
imagine qui aura effectivement des
points d'amélioration au point de vue du
hardware là dessus pour le s9 plus pour
l'instant pas d'information sur la
batterie c'était une 3500 clients
terreur on peut très bien imaginer une
3700 milliards d'eur pourquoi pas une
hypothétique 4 millions perreard là on
rêve un peu on apprend que l'appareil
photo va évoluer alors pas sur le nombre
de capteurs sur le s9 vous aurez un seul
appareil photo à l'arrière comme vous
l'aviez sur le s 8 par contre sur le s9
plus sa cabine ça vous aurez un double
capteur qui sera effectivement passé à
l'arrière comme sur le s fut de plus par
contre le grand intérêt et la grande
révolution par rapport à tout ça c'est
que sur ses nouveaux smartphones vous
allez pouvoir faire du super slow motion
ça on retrouve des accents des
smartphones de sony ça ne saoule prendre
pas en vous proposant du super slow
motion jusqu'à 1000 images par seconde
on doit aussi avoir une caméra qui va
monter un petit peu en pixels au lieu de
12 mégapixels londres est passé à 16
mégapixels avec une ouverture standard
de 1.7 et normalement on devrait pouvoir
avoir une ouverture réglable ce qui
serait une première sur les smartphones
ça serait vraiment top ce qui
permettrait d'aller plus loin dans la
photo d'aller plus loin dans la vidéo
est de toute façon on voit très bien
c'est ce que samsung cherche qu'ils
veulent c'est avoir des créateurs de
contenu ils ont très bien compris
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on disait que le
smartphone c'est de l'utilisation de
création film on fait des photos on se
prend celle fit donc il faut la bonne
qualité d'ailleurs on l'a vu aussi sur
le a8 plus qui sortira en il 18 oui bon
brouille un peu oui d'ailleurs il
sortira début 2018 donc ce à 8 plus vous
avez une double caméra avant celle
fillon voit qu'ils vont vraiment plus
loin avec des meilleurs sous verture
meilleure luminosité donc des
smartphones qui vont vraiment progressé
à priori l'écran avant ne changerait pas
en termes de dimensions par contre les
bords en haut et en bas prendrait un peu
moins de place ce qui fait que
l'appareil serait un peu plus compact on
garderait un écran super amoled écran
infiniti avec un ratio 18 points 5/9 ans
qu hd plus on aurait toujours une dague
de 5 g 8 pouces pour le s9 et 6,2 pour
le s9 plus toujours un écran bord à bord
on reste dans l'immersion un produit
légèrement plus compact et surtout avec
une sensation encore plus immersive du
fait de ne pas avoir ces petits bords
façon tout bord du bac il devrait être a
priori réduit et surtout ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on voit qu'ils ont
pas fait le choix comme apple d'avoir un
écran qui est tronqué en eau pour
laisser la place à la caméra trop d'eps
qui a été énormément critiqué le regard
des gens qui aiment et ce qu'ils
n'aiment pas samsung se dit moi mon
écran il est entier il est d'une seule
pièce et je n'ai pas du tout nous
retrouver avec un évident qu'il revient
[ __ ] le bordel donc ça c'est aussi
intéressant c'est vraiment une prise de
parti d'ailleurs dit moi vous qu'est ce
que vous en pensez est ce que l'idée de
d'apple de mettre sa caméra trop de bugs
qui vient vraiment faire une petite
encoche est ce que vous trouvez ça joli
est ce que ça vous dérange si vous avez
un iphone 10 est ce que ça vous dérange
ou excuse est plutôt fan aficionados
comme fait samsung sur son et suit
ensuite plus est a priori s9 s9 plus
d'avoir un écran entier sans coupure
d'ailleurs en parlant de ça ce qui est
intéressant c'est que a priori samsung
utiliserait également une caméra on se
rapproche un peu les technologies qu'on
trouve sur l'iphone 10 alors pas
nécessairement le terme trop d'absents
mais on dirait vraiment dans ce sens là
on sait très bien qu'ils aient eu
quelques problèmes à la sortie ou des
personnes ont réussi à déverrouiller
leur appareil directement avec une photo
ça ça a fait couler un peu d'encre
d'ailleurs on rejoint aussi le côté
ingrédients artificiels des smartphones
qui sont capables vraiment de mieux
comprendre le contexte de la photo de
mieux mais lioret avec toute une flopée
de capteurs ça sert vraiment aussi un
sens c'est super intéressant et ça me
sont cons ça devrait également son
scanner d'iris en l'améliorant petit peu
mais ça c'est quelque chose qui à priori
fonctionner bien d'ailleurs si vous
l'avez dit moi si vous avez déjà des
retours négatifs là dessus mais bon moi
j'ai rien vu j'ai en l'ayant essayé
plusieurs fois bon j'ai rien vu de
particulier dessus ça m'a choqué ça
donne soif de parler
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
voit c'est que le capteur d'empreinte
digitale sera placée sous l'appareil
photo et non plus à côté pour éviter de
positionner le doigt sur l'appareil
photo passe quelque chose qui avait été
vraiment reprocher à samsung s'est
améliorée c'est vraiment un point
positif donc on le retrouvera en dessous
un côté un peu plus ergonomique le flash
sera positionné à côté du capteur que ce
soit sur le s9 et sur le s9 plus coûté
performance qu'on devrait avoir un
snapdragon
845 pour les états unis et la chine et
pour l'europe et le reste du monde on
devrait avoir un exynos
9810 un s9 en 4 gigas à un s9 plus en 6
gia serait proposé à la base avec une
capacité de stockage de 128 gignac on
peut toujours monter avec une carte
micro sd alors est-ce qu'ils vont monter
aux deux terrasses heurte à pareille
baisse comparé à pied jusqu'aux 250
gigas peut-être 512 bon ça pour
l'instant pas trop d'infos là dessus il
devrait tenir son auréole 8.0 avec une
surcouche samsung touch with comme je le
disais il concerne la prise jack de
l'usbc une certification
ip68 un haut parleur unique qu'on
retrouve en bas de l'appareil les
rumeurs avaient fait état une époque que
samsung pourrait l'annoncer aux crs
début janvier à las vegas a priori il
l'annoncerait au mwc à barcelone fin
février début mars ça reste à voir de
toute façon moi le csj serait donc si je
le vois je le prendrais tout en photo je
vais partagerez je serai bien évidemment
des vidéos dessus donc rassurez vous les
infos on les aura en primaire d'ailleurs
invite à vous abonner pour avoir toutes
les infos en exclu et en avant première
un smartphone qui du coup devrait être
annoncée je vous lis fin février début
mars pour être commercialisé dès le mois
d'avril cette année ça va vraiment être
l'année de samsung en effectivement le à
8 à 8 plus que ça en début d'année le s9
s9 plus qui vont sortir après et on
attend effectivement l'annnonce du
galaxie ic ce qu'on attend depuis des
années non comment la rumeur pour
l'instant il ya vraiment trop rien
confirmer de la part de samsung six mecs
ils le sortiront quand ils sont prêts
mais vraiment l on voit que ce après
cela plus en plus d'infos donc on y
croit on croise les doigts et
normalement d 18 ça doit être une très
bonne année un très bon cru pour samsung
alors côté prix voilà ça c'est toujours
un truc un peu bas blesse le prix c'est
toujours à la hausse et qui c'est qui
paye dressez vous êtes toujours truc qui
fait un peu râler tout le monde alors
après il faut être cohérent il faut être
conscient parce que de toute façon les
produits m'ont en technologie il ya de
la recherche et développement où il ya
des produits qui coûtent cher sur les
écrans qui coûte cher même si
effectivement les écrans samsung on sait
très bien que c'est eux qui les
fabriquent avec leur futur samsung
displayed mais il ya quand même un
certain coût donc les produits de toute
façon coûte cher on sait très bien que
le s 8 avait été vendu à 900 à 809 euros
à sa sortie et le s est plus un peu plus
cher 909 euros si je vous dis pas de
bêtises on a vu que le galaxy note suite
allait passer la barre des 1000 euros
alors j'imagine que de toute façon se
produit le s9 s9 plus resteront petit
peu en dessous des 1000 euros pour être
cohérent par rapport à la gamme note il
plus cher on va éviter de mettre des
galaxy note de 9 à 1500 euros 1300 ont
déjà très très très cher sur ces
produits là donc on peut imaginer des
produits autour de 850 euros
950 euros ce qui fait déjà quand même un
très très beau budget alors le but pour
samsung c'est quoi ben déjà d'écraser la
concurrence ils veulent vraiment écrasé
apple c'est vraiment une guerre des
territoires une guerre des tranchées
avec ses smartphones qui sait ces
nouvelles technologies et ses côtés
innovants on va vraiment qu'il ya un
écart qui se creuse entre à mon avis les
deux grandes bases fans ce qu'ils sont
pro apple ceux qui sont trop samsung
contrairement à ce qu'on a dit je suis
pas pro apple je suis équipé apple et
vous savez ce que c'est quand on est
équipé apple bah c'est compliqué d'en
sortir parce que vous avez un écosystème
qui fonctionnent ensemble moi j'ai par
exemple un iphone 6 s une watch qui nie
pas là qui est d'ailleurs en charge j'ai
un macbook pro dont ça fonctionne
ensemble donc si jamais je passais chez
samsung qu'il va falloir que je n'aurais
équipe et ça ça un couvent sac un petit
peu embêtant et qui souvent bloque du
fait de pouvoir switcher d'un fabricant
à un autre mais j'adore les produits
samsung je cuisine sommes vraiment et
qu'il ya un vrai parti pris pour les
créateurs donc le but c'est de battre
apple c'est de séduire tous les
créateurs de contenu tous les photos
fils toutes les personnes qui veulent
des baux smartphones samsung en 2018 va
voir une gaine toujours étendu mais avec
des produits toujours plus séduisant
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez qu
est ce que vous attendez de ce téléphone
est ce 9ème plus est ce que vous êtes
pro samsung est ce que vous êtes pro
apple est ce que vous êtes protégé
prot au nord pro-ouattara d'ottmar qui a
énormément d'autres marques font de très
très bons produits dites moi quel
smartphone vous avez qu'est ce que vous
attendez de votre smartphone est-ce que
vous pensez que les s 9,9 plus vont
répondre à vos attentes mark et moi tout
sans commentaire on va en discuter
ensemble quand un mois vous remercie
d'avoir regardé la vidéo vous invite
année ces deux jolies pose à vous
abonner on va aller encore plus loin on
va aller au cls d'ici quelques jours
donc rester connecté abonnez-vous je
vous embrasse soyez sages portez vous
bien et à bientôt câble